here you
well, good morning.
That was all right.
I've got to tell you how pleased I am to be
with you and
the leadership here reached out
on Thursday. I think it was my days have
kind of gotten confused.
I think it was Thursday and they said Hey
in light of the tornado if you can't make it,
that's fine. We understand we got you covered.
And the more I thought about it.
The more I said, no, I need to be with Henderson.
number one
Jill and my family and I we've gotten to love
you and the congregation and pastor and
the elders we've come
to love you.
secondly, just the thought of
the normal sea of preaching God's word
Resonated with me and so what I'm
going to do is speak from
my heart about what God has revealed
in his word.
The Book of Joel I'm also going to talk kind of
personally
about something that we've been experiencing in
the past 72 hours or so.
That can only be described as a
miracle of God and then how we should respond to that.
So let me talk to you a little bit about the Book of
Joel, you know, there are books in the Bible that you kind of
feel like are barely in the Bible.
And for most of us, that's a lot of the Old Testament
now as an Old Testament professor.
I love all the books in the Bible even those that
seem barely there like Joel or
Obadiah. Yes. There is an Obadiah all
21 verses of it.
Or Nahum actually most of
the Minor Prophets. They're called Minor Prophets
so surely they can't be that important, right?
minor
Well Minor Prophets don't mean anything like
they're kind of relatively unimportant minor
just simply has to do with the size of the book.
But these are Minor Prophets with major themes.
And so these realities that God exposes
from these books listen to
me.
whether you're 10
or a hundred
God wants to speak to you.
God wants to engage you and me and so
the Book of Joel is one voice
in a chorus of 12 voices called
the Minor Prophets and
the Book of Joel is kind of like a key because all
of the themes all of the
theological realities all of the words that God has
given in the Minor Prophets find kind of
their nextest point in the teaching of the Book of Joel. So
if you understand Joel
You can kind of understand the rest of the Minor Prophets.
So what we want to do over the next few weeks is walk
through Joel now. There's some
weird stuff in there. I'm not gonna lie to you. I mean the title of
today's message is lessons from
a locust.
You might be thinking. What are we gonna talk about bugs all
week? Well, we're gonna yeah, we're gonna talk about bugs.
Yeah, we are.
We're going to talk about locusts.
And we're going to do that because Joel talks about locusts.
And you might be thinking well, what's a locust? Is that a grasshopper or
is that a cicada?
I don't know. I I don't know I actually do know but
you'll learn with me what it is.
It's custom weird things in there. But here's what I have confidence in.
If you hang with me.
If you walk with me through the word
of God.
And if you unclog your ears to hear
God's voice.
And here's the great miracle this morning.
God wants to speak to you.
Doesn't matter what you did last night.
Doesn't matter how far from God you are in this
room.
It doesn't matter how close you perceive that you are to God
right now in this room. Listen to me my friends.
God wants to speak.
to you
So if we unclog our ears.
Be attentive to God's voice.
He'll speak.
So I'm going to ask you to follow along with me as I
open God's word.
We're gonna unpack the first chapter of Joel. So
just
Hang with me we're going to read 20 or so verses.
And follow along. I'm reading from the ESV.
On the word of the Lord that came to Joel.
Anybody in this room named pethuel?
Didn't think so.
Verse two here this you Elders give ear all inhabitants
of the land has such a thing.
Happened in your days or in the days of your forefathers.
Tell your children of it let your children tell their
children and their children to another generation and here
we get to verse 4 about the bugs.
What the cutting Locust is left the swarming Locust is
eaten what the swarming Locust has left. The hopping Locust
is eaten, but the hopping Locust is left the destroying
locusts has eaten that's a lot
of different kind of locusts.
awake
you drunkards and weep and wail all you
drinkers of wine because of the sweet wine for it's
cut off from your mouth.
For a nation has come up against my land powerful
Beyond number its teeth or lion's teeth
and it has the fangs of a lioness. It is
laid waste by Vine and splintered my fig tree.
It is stripped off their bark and thrown it down their branches are
made white.
Verse 8 lament Like a Virgin wearing sackcloth
for the bridegroom of her youth the grain offering and
the drink offering are cut off from the house of the Lord the priests
mourn the Ministers of the Lord. The
fields are destroyed the ground Mourns because the grain
is destroyed the wine dries up and the oil languishes.
Be ashamed of tillers of the soil. Well, oh
Vine dressers for the wheat and The Barley
because the Harvest of the field has perished.
Isn't this just a happy book?
I mean you think wow, I feel really encouraged.
Especially after tornado. This is probably not the best
book to read.
The vine dries up. The Fig Tree language is pomegranate palm
and apple all the trees of the field are dried up
and gladness dries up from the children of man
put on.
Sackcloth and lament o priests whale o
Ministers of the altar go in past the night
and sackcloth the Ministers of my God because drain offering
and drink offering are withheld from the house of your
God consecrate a fast.
Call a solemn assembly gather the elders and all
the inhabitants of the land to the house of the
Lord your God and you need to underline this phrase
cry out.
to the Lord and then verse 15
introduces a reality called
the day of the Lord and I'm
going to unpack that in just a minute, but
The day of the Lord is a concept in a
reality that actually friends you and I need to understand.
Because it sets a pattern.
For what we see in the ministry of
Jesus you say what? Yes
If you can understand the day of the Lord, you can understand what Jesus is
doing at the cross and the resurrection.
The less you understand of the day of
the Lord the less you'll understand the cross and Resurrection.
So the day of the Lord is really really important. In
fact, the day of the Lord is considered by some to be
the central idea in the minor the prophets
and here we get a picture of the day of the Lord.
You ready?
Last it comes there's an interesting word play in the Hebrew. The
almighty here is El Shaddai.
The word for Destruction there is should.
So should I should it's a
word play that that Joel is using here. That's a
little poetry for you.
Verse 16 is not the food cut off before our eyes
joy and gladness from the house of our God the seeds.
Shrivel under the clods. The storehouses are desolate. The
granaries are torn down because the grain is
dried up how I love this. This is so interesting.
how the beasts grown
the herds of cattle are perplexed because
there's no pasture for them.
Even the flocks of sheep. Suffer To
You O Lord I call.
For fire has devoured the pastures of the wilderness.
And Flame has burned all the trees of the field even the
beasts of the field can't for
you.
Because the water Brooks are dried up
and the fire has devoured pastures the wilderness.
From this passage chapter 1 we're going
to take some lessons.
And these lessons begin and end with
a locust.
Now what you need to understand about this passage of scripture is
Joel chapter 1 is really about
destruction. In fact, the Book of
Joel can be divided up into two halves destruction or
judgment and restoration or
salvation. That's the Book of Joel in a nutshell.
So for the first
Few weeks. We're going to be talking about judgment and destruction. You said
that's kind of a downer. I don't like talking about that. I didn't write
the book. I don't mean what do you want me to do?
So we got to go with what God is giving us.
Thing that I want us to look at in the first lesson.
is this
Okay lesson number one.
We find In this passage is God's word is
true and reliable. There are a
lot of things that we can lean on in our lives.
I mean in the west especially.
We have jobs.
We've got communities.
We've got friends and family.
If I can be blunt, we've got money.
There are a lot of things we can lean on.
But there's one thing that we need to lean on.
most
God
and his word
and students if I can grab your
attention for just a minute.
And making appeal to you.
Please hear me when I say.
The lord loves you.
He gives you his word because he loves you.
And that word is good.
It is true.
And it's reliable you can build your life on it.
Now the reason I say this is because when we
look at the lesson from the Locust the Locust reminds God's
people that his word is true.
And it can be relied upon God's word
is true. We can take God's word to the bank. It's reliable
we can build our lives on it
God's word is secure.
How do we know this from a humble little
Locust I want you to look at verse 4 again. Look
at verse 4.
Verse 4 is a strange little verse isn't
it? There's a lot of bugs there cutting locusts has
left the swarming Locust has eaten swarming Locust
is left. The hopping Locust is eaten hopping Locust
is left the destroying Locust has eaten. There are
a lot of different Locust described there. Now people like
me, you know go to nerd conventions and
we talk about these things. Oh, yes. This is a finest blah
blah blah. No.
As probably not what is going on here.
In fact, this is describing in you
know, interesting detail the
idea of an ancient near Eastern Locust plague.
And what you got to understand is in the ancient world particularly in
the land of Israel. They would have these giant Locust
swarms they still do today.
these Locust swarms grasshoppers
that come they multiply Waters come rains come
and in certain seasons of the year and all the sudden all
these locusts grow and then they swarm and
when I say swarm they cover everything.
And they eat.
Everything so if they hit a field the field is gone.
now in that world
Here's what you got to understand. It's not
like you can go to McDonald's and buy a hamburger and get some food. This
is an agrarian economy. What that means is it's
run and fueled by produce.
And farming and agriculture. Okay, and
if you have a natural disaster like
a locust plague.
You don't have any food more than that. You don't have any
kind of anything to trade.
It's an agrarian economy. So we're talking
about Locust play. You might just say oh man what an inconvenience
a bunch of bugs. No.
This is the life threatening plague.
And so when there's this conversation about a locust
plague that's coming immediately. You
think a threat to my livelihood a threat
to my life my children my family my
community. It's about to be wiped out the Locust plague.
Is significant but it teaches us a lesson.
The Locust plague reminds God's people of
something important. Now how many of you
have these devices?
Some of you are looking at them right now.
You know, how on an Instagram feed you you kind of
if you set it up if you look at your Instagram feed
and you you see a real you
can work on your story or something like that. What you
can do is you can set up a number of pictures or short
videos, you know.
This picture and then this picture in this picture and it just goes through a
timeline where all these pictures show up. You don't talk about.
What you need to understand is the Bible is kind
of like that.
It gives this picture and then this picture and then
this picture and it kind of just like
story
You as the reader are kind of given the
task of hey put all these things together. How does
this story all work this picture and this picture. How does all fit together?
That's what's going on. When the Locust plague shows
up. It's kind of like Memories.
aren't memories funny
when you smell something.
Memory might be a perfume.
Or a cologne you think oh that reminds me of
that or you walk into your grandmother's house.
You smell that food.
And you think all the good old days when I
didn't have any responsibility. I was just a kid.
right
or you walk into a school?
And you see something.
You think oh, do you remember when?
Or you go to a location and it brings back
good or bad?
Memories memories are funny.
Because something that you see smell hear
touch could be
a song you hear the song you think. Oh, man. I feel
like I'm being transported back.
To the 90s, you know.
Memories are funny.
Something that we see or hear triggers our
memory and it draws us back
to something that's happened in the past, you know.
The Bible and the Lord because
he made us he knows this and so one of the key ways that
the Bible communicates is through the activation and
the triggering of memory. How do I know this?
Do you know the Locust plague?
Is a memory trigger?
In fact, when you look at the Old Testament in particularly,
the Locust plague draws
God's people back to what God has
done in the past.
the Locust plague
the Locust plague now what you need to understand. There are a
lot of ways to understand this Locust play. They could be a real
kind of natural disaster that could be an image
or a metaphor of an invading Nation.
It could be some sort of combination of the two. In fact
what you got going on in this passage the
Locust plague.
Is conjoining this idea of a natural
disaster and an invading Army?
And it's doing so for a purpose to say God's people
are under threat.
But because it's a locust plague it's drawing their
memory back to what God's been doing and saying
in the past through his word check this out.
It's 10.
indicates God's plagues against Egypt
And you know, one of those plagues in Israel's memory is it's
a locust place.
Check this out Deuteronomy 28 Deuteronomy 28
depicts God's covenant curse against this people and
you know what one of the curses against his people when they disobeyed God's
word.
Locust plague
so you got Israel experiencing God's Deliverance through
a locust plague against Egypt Exodus 10.
You've got the Locust plague.
indicating
God's Judgment of his own people and Deuteronomy 28 check this out.
Look.
Psalm 78
Echoes both Exodus 10 and the
failure of Israel in the pentateuch again through the Locust plague.
What about First Kings 8
this
text
Is where Solomon is crying out to God?
Talking to God in prayer and it depicts this Locust plague
as an enemy Invasion and indicates
Divine punishment. Do you see what's going on here?
Joel
Is triggering the memory of
God's word now. Here's the question. Why?
Because Joel is wanting to communicate.
That God's word is true.
And rule about you. Remember what God has done in the past. God
said what happened particularly if Israel disobeys
what happened to Egypt is going to happen to Israel
God's going to judge them because of their sin and Rebellion
against him.
Guess what?
The Locust plague is here an enemy
invasion is on the rise.
So the Locust plague triggers the memory of God's
word in judgment. What does
this teach us?
Listen to me God's word is true.
now
there are a lot of people in this room. There'll be a lot of people in the room to in
the next hour. Here's what I
will say to you not everyone actually believes that in this
room.
Not everyone actually believes God's word
is true and reliable.
He said well if I'm here on a Sunday, of course I do.
well
You know, I've I've worked in six churches in
three states and two countries.
right
and one of the things that I know
Is people are people and in a room this size you
got folks sitting in different seats, right? And one of
the seats could be I'm close to God. One of the seats could
be I'm far from God and one of the seats could be I don't care.
And because of that reality we know that
there are different people come into this room at different places.
And different places of trust and belief of God and his word
and I understand that.
Here's what I would say to you and let me appeal to you as a
friend.
Joel
is reminding us through the Locust.
That God's word is true. If God says Rebellion
against him or neglect of him.
leads to disaster
that word is not an empty word and idle word or a
worthless word.
It's a true word.
And it's a good word. Why?
Because God's not doing it giving us this word
because he's mad.
He's given us this word because he loves us. Why sin and
Rebellion against God are neglect of
God.
Leads to disaster in your life and mine.
The first thing that I want to see from this lesson is
where are you in this room?
Maybe you're an out Rebellion against God or
just neglect like well, it's kind of like this. He's I I
like the word. I like God's word.
But you know, I'll get to it when I get to it. I want to
live my life a little bit.
I'm not rebelling against God. I'm just you know,
it's in my own time.
God's word has come. It's true. It's reliable In
this passage. It's a word of judgment.
Rebellion against God brings disaster
Rebellion is this active rejection
of what God has said for our lives.
The neglect that I was speaking about is a passive rejection
either way.
We're trying to approach God and his word on our terms.
God doesn't let us do that.
Whether an act of rebellion against God's word or passive neglect
of God's word. The reality is judgment is the
natural outcome of drawing away from God in
his word for Israel. This meant the land mourning
it meant animals suffering. It meant
famine it meant lack of worship it meant people
suffering and the entire land more.
The priests can't offer sacrifices why because
the people can't bring offerings.
They can't bring wine offerings. And so the wine dries
up from the land there can't be worship. This is
bad news.
lesson from the locusts
Now here's what we know.
If God's word of judgment is true my friends then listen.
God's word of Salvation is true as well.
And that's an incredibly comforting thought.
God teaches us in the scripture that
if we listen to his voice, we will find forgiveness
healing life purpose today
and forever my friends. We don't have to walk
aimlessly through life.
I'll just go to my cubicle make some dollars.
And just kind of muddle my window you don't have to lift that way.
Our God has something better for you to set
you on purpose
but he's giving us our word his words so that we can hear his voice.
And when we hear his voice and his offer
of Salvation we say yes.
We see here his word of forgiveness. We say
yes, we see here is word for life and
we say yes.
Judgment is not God's first word in
Scripture.
It will not be God's last word.
God's first word for you and me is life joy peace
communion and relationship and you say Heath in
light of all this dark passage in Joel One. How can
you say that because I Look To the Cross
and we know this from when I was here about five years
ago.
And we walk through the Gospel of John together. Do you remember that?
And in the Gospel of John, do you know what John says about?
Jesus and God
for God so
loved
the world
That he condemned everybody to hell. Is that no what?
No, that's not what it says for God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son. Do you
remember this?
And whoever believes in him.
Should not perish.
But have everlasting life God's first word
for you and me is life.
But when we turn away from God's word.
disaster follows
knowing that God went to the far country of our sin in
Christ.
To bring us home.
Do you hear his word today?
That leads us to our second lesson.
God's word
requires response
God's word requires response.
I think it's fascinating in chapter one how many
imperatives shows up?
Imperatives are commands in the
Bible right imperatives or commands in English their commands
in Hebrew their commands in Greek imperatives. Are
this do this do that?
Don't do this. Don't do that. That's an imperative.
and if you look in this passage, you see a number of
imperatives why because when
God's word is given
human beings are required to respond.
God's word offers both death and life for
Israel In this passage.
For those who listen it's life for those
who refuse its death. Either way God's word
requires response. Look at the text.
I want you to look at various verses verses 8 and
13 God's people here personified
as a lady's Zion.
God's people should lament and mourn over
the loss of the relationship with God.
Verses 9 and 13 carry this image of lost forward
the priests.
Suffer the loss of people bringing sacrificial meals and are
called to repent.
and more
In verse 14 the whole land is ravaged and
God commands for a formal fast
in verse 14, but the point here is there
are various commands.
to lament and mourn
And to call a fast what's this the picture of lament and
mourn and fast, it's a picture of
repentance. What's the first response that God requires?
Repentance now what is repentance repentance can
be a lot of things. We think you know, it's just kind of saying God
my bad. I'll be better. No, that's not
worth appendices repentance is literally I
am walking this way.
God gets hold of my life.
And I turn around this way that's repenting
turning.
It's the idea that God has a
way and a word for my life and I am not listening
to it when I hear it. I turn.
I like the way that CS Lewis describes it. What am
I Heroes the CS Lewis in his book Mere Christianity. He
says this
Fallen man is not simply an imperfect creature
who needs Improvement.
He's a rebel who must lay down his
arms. What he's saying here is that repentance
is really not just only about turning this
way and going this way.
He's actually upping the ante and he's saying if we
recognize our fallen State our Rebellion
against God, actually we've got arms.
Guns that we're pointing against God.
Now that's silly for humans to do. We've got the Transcendent God
creator of the universe.
and then there's us
what chance do we have none?
But he captures it. He sees it. He understands it.
Look what he says.
Laying down his arms laying down your arms surrendering
saying you're sorry realizing you've been on the
wrong track and getting ready to start life over again
from the ground floor. That's the only way out of
the hole.
This process of surrender this movement full speed
of stern.
is repentance
See, that's what God is calling for in John
1.
fast mourn lament repent
my friends in your life and mine.
Martin Luther says it this way.
Repentance is the door of the
Christian Life.
You want to know how to get on track with God?
Lay down your arms.
Turn around and run into the
arms of the God. Who saves you.
That's repentance.
And that's what God is calling for with.
these good people
That's the first response that the Locust teaches us if
you see the locusts repent.
Second action that we see in this passage.
Is this phrase cry out call out
to God for help?
Cry out call out to God for help.
Where we put down our guns?
And say Lord, I need you.
It's no surprise that the culminating imperative
or command that we receive in chapter one is in
verse 14 cry out.
Or Yahweh are the Lord in your translations?
Now this phrase cry out to God or the
Lord is a prayer for help. Do you know where else this
phrase shows up?
Exodus 2:23 where Israel
were slaves in Egypt
And what happens is in verses 23 and 24
of Exodus 2 is God's people suffering
under Affliction and slavery. They
look to God and they say we're in Dire Straits and
we and the languages the same in the Hebrew. They cry out
to God for help.
Now why do they do that?
Because there's only one voice that can save and
deliver.
And it's the voice of God.
When you and I are experiencing extraordinary pain and suffering
and life whether it's self-inflicted the
work of enemies or even when
we feel forgotten by God.
We're in pain and suffering.
The Bible over and over and over again draws us
to this point in Joel 1:14, then again in verse
19 I call to God. I I not that
day or you or someone else I call to
God.
This cry for help.
Is real why because God's people know.
There's only one who's powerful to save.
Because God loves us.
He loves to respond.
to our Christ
for help
I don't I've been praying about this how to
do this.
But this last Point has been very
personal for me and my family in
the past 72 hours.
When do we cry to God for help?
We cry to God for help when we're in pain.
We cry to God for help and we're confused.
We cry to God for help and we don't know what to do.
We cry to God for help when we are at the end of our
tether and we feel like we're about to fall in the
chasm. We cry to God for help.
Whenever life throws a curveball or Turns Upside
Down.
And I got to tell you in the past 72 hours, it
feels that way in up in my community.
Looking at the devastation of the tornado.
I got to tell you it's a miracle of God that no lives were
lost.
no injuries
It's in it's unbelievable walls torn
down portions of buildings ripped
off completely structural degradation.
Rayleigh Chapel is our one of our most iconic
buildings and when the tornado hit
and ripped
tonnage
up off of the ceiling.
We had about a couple hundred students in the basement in a
shelter.
And I got to tell you.
It's unbelievable.
That no lives were lost.
I look out across the devastation. We have 1.2 million
square feet on our campus.
Where 47 to 50 buildings depending on
how you're counting on our campus?
We have structural damage. Every building was impacted.
tree limbs two by fours inside of buildings
dumpsters big dumpsters
were carried hundreds of yards in the
air.
And hurled down to the ground.
a giant storage steel storage
container a 40 foot storage container
Was lifted in the air it was full.
And it was lifted in the air.
And landed on our baseball field.
destroying up
a pole and the entire storage container was
wrapped around this.
Pole light pole what I'm saying to you is it's unbelievable
what we've experienced.
The tornado was as big.
As our campus it hit the airport beside us
and into the communities all around us for at least
a mile and a half.
unbelievable
and when I think about that and I think about the lives that
are impact and I think about my seniors who are about
to graduate. You know, what our seniors have been through you. Could
you guys know?
covid
polar vortex going online I
Storm of the Century
inflation at a 50 year high
the great resignation. I mean all of these things and
now a tornado
where is the blood where's the frogs? Where's the boil? I
mean, it's crazy.
But in times like this, this is what we can do.
We can learn the lesson from the Locust.
And we can respond.
and what I've discovered is
our God is a very present help in times of trouble.
and when we cry out
because we serve a loving God.
He loves to respond to our Christ.
So, can I get in your business a little bit?
I'm going to anyway, that was just a preacher thing
to do ask permission.
I'm gonna get in your business.
Do you have a family member or a son or
a daughter that's gone away and you don't know what to do.
Maybe you're battling substance Addiction in this
room.
Or some sort of addiction in the Stream.
And you're at the end of your rope. You don't know what to do.
You've got past hurt. You can't get past.
You have family trouble. You got work trouble. You lost your
job.
These things are not trivial to our God.
He already knows them.
The opportunity that we have from The Book of Joel.
Is to hear God's word.
and respond
maybe today you need to repent.
You've never come into a saving relationship with the God who made
you and the God who saved you.
And you've been neglecting God. Oh, I'll respond to mind
on my time. It's kind of like you think it's a
it's like those, you know telemarketers who call and you say
are you interested in this special offer? No, not today. I'll get back to
it. Later.
Here, can I just encourage you?
We don't respond to God in our time.
when I want to
when God's word is given.
the time of response is
now
we respond now.
So if you're neglecting God's word and say oh I'll
get to it on my time.
You don't if there's anything I know after the
past 72 hours. We're not guaranteed tomorrow.
Today is the day of salvation for you.
Some of us in this room are experiencing extreme pain and hurt.
And you've already asked the Lord to forgive you
of your sin. You've turned you've laid down your arms, but you're
going through some stuff. You don't quite know how to deal with.
God's given us a word to which we can respond.
cry out to him
As best I know how to say it.
God will meet us.
God will hear us.
And God will answer us now.
I can guarantee you maybe his answer.
Might not be the answer. We were hoping for or looking for.
I've been asking God and Les knows this
in the past three years since I've been a president at OBU we've
been praying for divine favor wisdom insight
and miracles.
Well, I believe God's answering.
But I don't think I would have ever wanted him
to answer the way that he's answered.
now
God's response and the way God answers our Christ for help
or his business. Not ours.
Our job is just to trust him.
The important thing you need to hear from from
me today. Is that God hears our Christ?
So you can cry.
He loves you.
I want to invite you to stand with me.
And I want to pray over you.
lessons from the Locust
God's word is true.
And God's word requires response. How are you
going to respond today?
Our Father we thank you